[Music]
thank you
welcome to this special edition of The
Sky News Daily podcast where we're
taking a look at some of the stories
which Define 2022 and how they might
shape our lives in the future over five
special episodes we'll cover the economy
the royal family the war in Ukraine and
climate change but on this episode we
are looking at the tumultuous year in
politics and if you are watching you
might just be able to tell that we are
here in our Westminster studio and
joining us our political editor Beth
Rigby Beth lovely to see you and first
things first that is a snazzy top yes
Neil I have put on my Christmas jumper
especially for this podcast Edition it's
given me quite a lot of Joy
um I hope it gives our viewers Joy too
but I don't mind if you also think it's
a bit over the top but it's my Christmas
jumper and it's a Christmas podcast I
think the listeners on the podcast don't
know what a favor they have done by just
listening um let us reflect on on 2022
and again I'm I am not someone who is as
plumbed into the Westminster Machinery
As You Are on but I have never known a
year in politics like it you'd agree I
would agree and actually you've just put
up on the screen I know the podcasters
can't see that but there's the three
prime ministers now I've been political
at Sky News since May 2019 and when I
took the job I thought if I'm lucky I
might see the Handover of power once or
twice I didn't expect to see three prime
ministers through the door at number 10
in in four months and I actually checked
with Adam Bolton the great Adam Bolton
who was Pollard here for 25 years I said
Adam how many new Prime Ministers did
you see go through doing he said four in
25 years so it gives you a perspective
about the turmoil and actually the um
Collins Dictionary
gave the word of 2020 to their word of
2022 was parama Crisis and that
basically means the feeling of living
through a period of War inflation and
political turmoil and that does
encapsulate doesn't it the year of 2022
but from my part I mean Ed did the
economy I mean I did the political
turmoil and it was tumultuous and it was
a bit Bonkers I I was reflecting for a
while on where we should start our
discussion but but of course it has to
be with with with Boris Johnson and his
demise but actually we need to rewind I
think to to the tail end of 2021 when
that video emerged of the then comms
director at number 10 Allegra Stratton
essentially confessing to the fact that
a party had happened or something
similar fast forward into January of
that year and Boris Johnson at the very
least had to admit that he had attended
events he didn't believe there were
parties that was the beginning of the
end I think it was the beginning of the
end and actually to put that into
context Neil this was the gun it was
only this week on December the 12th it
was that um March the third anniversary
of that Landslide electoral Victory do
you remember yes ATC majority 2019
December 2019 the big biggest
conservative majority since the days of
Margaret Thatcher that guy was meant to
be in for certainly a term in office if
not two and as you said it began to all
unravel from January onwards and really
from January onwards we were in
political crisis and it waxed and waned
through the first half of the year but
it was the beginning of the end and it
wasn't necessarily the story of
partygate in itself
it was the handling of it by Johnson and
his team which was start with denial
then begin to admit things but don't
accept culpability and honest ambushed
by Cake ambushed by Cake
um no one told me I remember that
interview I did with the pm he said no
one told me it wasn't okay
um and it went on and on and on and
really it was a fascinating time now
because if 2021 had been the year of
covid so at 2020 and 2021
they win a massive majority were then
plunged into the covid crisis from Jan
2020 onwards and then 2022 was almost
the year where Johnson could have
started what he wanted to do in that
Premiership because everything had been
stalled by covid and yet what happened
in practice was a government in
political turmoil because of partygate
the crisis his handling of the crisis
and what we saw the first six months of
that year was
um
really the the mistakes he made the
questions about his character and in the
end the Parliamentary party and members
of his government uh losing faith in him
and his ability to lead and also the
public I mean the polling was terrible
yeah they were firefighting they were
firefighting from January the first but
by my Reckoning that was certain that
was certainly his stated position but
there was a period where everyone here
in Westminster was waiting for remember
this name the Sue gray reports to find
out what was going on inside down street
now ultimately that didn't that didn't
amount to a huge amount that we didn't
know already instead it was a man called
Chris pincher that really started the
dominoes toppling at the end so the
thing about Chris pincher and this was
the deputy chief whip
um there were issues about he had
sexually harassed people uh I should say
um
these are claims that he refused just to
be clear
but that was really Neil the straw that
broke the camel's back because it's
often
um something that happens that's not
core to the actual sort of turmoil but
it signals something about the
leadership
um that really breaks breaks the dam I
never get to the heart whether or not
Boris so it's new so the issue was
that there had been claims made about
Chris pincher when he'd worked in the
foreign office with Boris Johnson as
foreign secretary and Boris Johnson said
I had never been made aware of any of
these issues around Chris pincher and it
was then Simon McDonald who was the
former permanent secretary the chief
civil servant at the foreign office who
then said I know this not to be true
because I personally told the Prime
Minister who was then foreign secretary
and that happened overnight and I
remember it I've interviewed Simon
McDonald about that since I said why did
you do it because you must have known
Your Role what your role would be in the
downfall and his view was I didn't
really understand the enormity of what
what would come to pass in terms of his
role in Boris Johnson's demise but he
just said I knew that to be an untruth
and someone had to call it out what
happened after that Neil was McDonald
put out a letter saying that is not true
and then became those Cascade of
resignations and and that was at the
beginning of the end and actually Boris
Johnson I think it was 48 hours later
was on the steps of down the street
handing in his resignation the thing
about prime minister is that they are
all powerful but their power really is
based on the pleasure if you like of
their back benches willing to support
them and wants that and their government
and wants that support is withdrawn a
prime minister is suddenly very weak and
he was he was forced out of down the
street he made it very clear didn't want
to go remember he said when the herd
moves it moves and it stampeded him well
you see you see he was a Downing Street
I mean he came outside said he was going
to step down at some point I went back
in and had another month doing the job
didn't he and talk to me a little bit
about that time in in the conservative
party because of course we went through
the Parliamentary process we had the
candidates not excuse me narrowed down
to Liz truss and Rishi sunak then it
went out to the membership and it was
brutal it wasn't true
the the thing about all of it from the
fall of Johnson to the rise of trust to
the fall of trust to now the bumping
along should I put it of sunak is
throughout of all of this
the characteristic has been the
infighting and the conservative party
and and you need to look at the kind of
what happened with the various leaders
through that lens so there was a a move
that Boris Johnson had to go he went
then what happened with Liz trust and
Rishi Suna well there were loads of
Runners and riders in that race
Boris Johnson although he never publicly
came out to support Liz trust privately
made it very clear that he was back in
Liz trust that precipitated
some of his key allies I'm thinking
Nadine Doris and Jacob Breeze Mustang
key members in the cabinet to publicly
endorse trust now the challenge for
trust was could she get to the
membership could she make it through to
the final two Rishi was the Rishi Suna
was the favorite with MPS he got past
the hundred mark and then it was a
battle between mordant and trust and
Trust just about one out and actually
the vote was so tight nil I think it was
four or five minutes so said it's all
eight votes in I think so had four or
five MPS switch sides it's like sliding
doors there would have been a completely
different process
the problem where she soon act had and
some of those close to him sort of
admitted this to me after the race
was there were about 30 percent of the
party members that would die hard Boris
Johnson backers so once Boris Johnson
had made it clear
that Rishi sunak was the traitor that
Rishi sunak had wielded the sword that
he was supporting Liz truss Rishi sunak
went through that very bruising
leadership race the whole summer
fighting knowing that he could not win
yeah well let's let's then talk to about
a bit of time to to the Liz trust
Premiership and given that she was in
power for 44 days we can probably wrap
up in a couple of minutes I would have
thought I don't know though because the
the the ramifications of those 44 days
were quite profound weren't they on
there totally but I mean it it strikes
me that that many budget which was not a
mini budget at all was again was was the
beginning of the end why did she and we
should not forget of course
why did this get it so wrong and why are
they still to this day to an extent
maintaining that the problems which
emerged immediately after that many
budget were problems that every other
country would experience at the same
time I mean look Liz truss hasn't spoken
publicly at all about what happened yet
quasi quattang how chancellor has a bit
and he has admitted that they didn't you
know bring people with them they went
too far they went too fast I mean she
sort of said a little bit of that when
she was still prime minister when when
she reversed that budget but what what
was going on it's a it's a good question
Neil and
you know Liz truss had a view and I she
still holds this view about the sort of
intellectual underpinning of what she
did that that Financial Orthodox fiscal
Orthodoxy was not going to Turbo Charge
the economy in a way she wanted so she
had a deregulately tax cut in uh small
state approach to the economy that she
thought you took pain now but you would
Turbo Charge growth and then over time
she would be proven right yeah and she
assembled a cabinet around her of
Believers that would not challenge her
on this quite radical economic plan
what was the mistake well Rishi sunat
would have argued the mistake was trying
to put that plan in place like this
because he warned about it you know
every single one of them I remember Rob
saying your economic policies are an
electoral suicide note for the
conservative party Rishi sunak called
them fantasy economics
but where did they go wrong in the mini
budget I remember sitting in the studio
and Ed Conway and I were watching it
unfold and she had made promises about
cutting corporation tax cutting income
tax there were huge tax cuts that Liz
truss had signaled but then she went
even farther and that was in a way what
spooked the market because she was
already at the limits maybe of what the
markets would tolerate and then she
doubled down on that and then it was
what it was what I can't remember the
figure now 45 billion of tax cuts I
think it was uh which were unfunded and
then that precipitated you remember the
steepest four pound fatal record low
Bank of England 65 billion uh Bond
buy-in program in order to prop up
Pension funds mortgages being withdrawn
over a thousand mortgages withdrawn from
the markets as interest rates which we
knew were going up went up more quickly
than anticipated and a lot of short-term
campaign and longer term pain for the
public we're gonna have to take a break
in just in just a second but of course
all of this increased the pressure
within the party owner till ultimately
it became impossible for her to cling on
but yet again it was the members that
got rid of her and the members that put
in Rishi sunak and and that has not sat
well has it with the Grassroots of the
party that's right so
look it was clear after the mini budget
and when Liz trust went to Party
Conference and she reversed her decision
on the cutting the 45 Pence tax rate the
Express and the mail her two big back in
newspapers had the wrong headlines on
the Monday morning because they
literally took the decision in the wee
hours of Sunday night right at that
point you're like this is it she's done
it's just a question of when is she done
her credibility was shot and then it
unraveled very quickly from that but as
you said what happened next was that
Boris Johnson was really seriously
considering a run to return he'd felt
he'd been wronged by being kicked out
there were a hundred MPS that wanted to
back him
but there were conversations that were
had over that weekend when he the
deadline was the Monday afterwards where
he uh was told in no uncertain terms
there is a core of the party that will
bat you but there are more that won't
you won't be able to command a
government you need 160 MPS uh to form a
government he couldn't do it and then
there was a sort of a view within the
party some people wanted a short runoff
between Penny mordant and Rishi sunak
and she nearly got to the number she got
to 93 94 you needed a hundred but then
some of her supporters switched and the
reason was there's a decision in the
party like we don't want to put this to
members again we want it done but you
are right they're there for as a
legitimacy issue with Rishi sunak
because he was picked by MPS not with
Grassroots and some of those people that
bat Boris and you saw it this weekend
with pretty Patel leading a Grassroots
campaign feel that the members have been
cut out of the decision-making process
and it's a very unhappy party we will
delve into that a little bit in just a
moment
um but after the break we will of course
be talking a lot more about Rishi sumac
Labor's future and that's what 2023 May
been for British politics who knows
[Music]
I will welcome back to this special
edition of The Sky News Daily podcast we
are here in Westminster with our
political editor Beth Rigby and and just
before we went into the breakbeth we
were talking about the problems that
that Rishi sunak May well have yeah but
but it kind of feels now that things
have slightly settled down you know in
terms of the fact we have Rishi sunak
leading the conservative party as prime
minister and we don't feel like he is
going anywhere there's no there's no the
knives might pay out for him but they're
not getting plunged into his back at the
moment and in Pierre starmer again the
labor party feels a bit more settled we
are starting to see the the dividing
lines on which the next election is
going to be fun yeah I think also what's
happened is we've moved away if you like
from personality politics more populist
instinctive people are you suggesting
that those two men don't have a
personality
I couldn't possibly say that Neil they
actually have quite a lot of personality
but when they get in front of the camera
both of them are much more controlled
actually they're much more personable
and and relaxed off camera both of them
where's Boris Johnson had a performance
to side to him like that he was in
performance mode whether on or off
camera but we've definitely gone back
towards away from personality politics
more to sort of issues of policy I think
the question for Rishi sunak and the
conservative party is whether you loved
or loathed Boris Johnson he put the
conservative party within touching
distance of Labor even once the party
gate had begun to die down the polls
were beginning to narrow again now with
Rishi sunup they're not really labor is
still Weller well ahead
um there's some questions about whether
or not if the conservatives do really
badly in the May elections next year
will there be a momentum from some in
the party to try and get Boris Johnson
back seriously genuinely Boris Johnson I
mean because he was came so close to
standing again of course as you
mentioned just I don't think he's given
up ambition really yeah and I mean look
let's see what happens with the
Privileges committee I mean part of what
happens to him is determined by that but
if we go back to who's in at the moment
um Rishi sunak I would say is sort of
performing a bit more as a technocrat at
the moment you know he's like a chief
operating officer it's like I will run
your government and I will try and have
good governance and I'm just going to
try and get things done of course he
stymied somewhat by the fact that the
country is in crisis at the moment and
it's not just about the cost of living
it's about strikes it's about inflation
it's about not being able to get a GP
appointment it's about immigration it's
about small boats there's so many big
policy issues and difficulties that he
as prime minister has to deal with and
meanwhile sirma
is presenting as the prime minister in
waiting and a government in waiting and
I thought what was very interesting was
earlier uh this month
um kirstama did a big launch on a huge
Devolution product uh project commission
actually uh that Gordon Brown had done
it's 155 Pages it was all about taking
power from Westminster and putting it
back into local communities
abolishing the House of Lords
restricting second jobs for MPS it was
It was kind of lofty but quite abstract
staff when people are worrying day to
day about how are they going to pay the
bills and can they get the kids what
they want for Christmas right I wrote a
story about this and it was one of the
most read stories on the website and I
was genuinely surprised I thought I'm
interested in that but I'm a political
geek like I love this stuff this is what
I live for you know but actually the
fact that a lot of people clicked onto
that story and they read it what does it
tell me people are taking another look
at Labor the challenge for labor over
the next two years over the next year
is that that guy kierstama he might have
political momentum might be 20 plus
points ahead in the polls but in terms
of the Electoral maths of how a election
in this country works it's still really
hard to see Neil how does he win an
outright majority
you know this you know this so well you
know you covered elections for Sky the
route through
to number 10 for the labor party goes
through Scotland and back in 2005 when
they won a 60-seat majority 41 of the
seats were in Scotland how many have
they got now Nicholas starchern is
dominant in Scotland and that's the
challenge really I think for here
starmer as well it's like he has the
political momentum he has the lead in
the polls in the end how do they
translate it into an outright majority
and the conservative party will come at
them with the same messaging that was in
the 2015 election which is vote for
labor get Nicola sturgeon in 2023 are
things going to calm down enough that I
might actually be able to get a set down
and perhaps a weekend of peace to myself
because to be fair you know we've had
this discussion I'm reflecting on the
events of the past 12 months there are
bits that I've forgotten there are bits
that I thought happened three years ago
I I think everyone could do with a
breather and the country could do with
getting sorted out look
the past 12 months have been insane but
we have you have to set the political
crisis in the context of external Global
events right that had an impact
domestically first it was covered then
it was war in Ukraine and what you can't
predict is what might happen Beyond
domestic politics that somehow Define
the era that we are living in I do think
though that the fall of Johnson and
Trust because they were kind of
politicians Cut From the Same Cloth
there is definitely a sort of different
approach to government maybe more a
conventional approach
but you can't discount external events
and also when you think about it yes
inflation will fall back hopefully at
the end of next year that's the
prediction but we still have uh strike
action coming up
um there's still huge questions about
the NHS uh we have got tax Rises coming
up public spending is going to be
subdued we've got the May local
elections so I do think it's going to be
and and what is going to happen in the
war with the war in Ukraine is it going
to escalate uh will it de-escalate much
will be defined by what Putin decides to
do over the next 12 months so I do think
from my perspective because I also quite
want to sit down on a cup of tea
so from my perspective I don't think
we're going to have the political chaos
that we had
um but you can't discount anything in
this game anymore and and let's see what
happens in those May local elections as
well well we will soon see Beth it's a
pleasure as well
thank you for being with us and if you
scan the QR code that will be appealing
on your screen right about now you can
subscribe to the Daily podcast listen
back to the chat with Beth plus all of
our other reviews of 2022.
so thanks very much for joining us we'll
see you next time
[Music]